foreign
and that's how you test
I don't think I had any idea what I was
getting into at the beginning of this
project
I've only seen a Florida panther twice
with my own eyes
the animals that we're trying to film
and photograph are super elusive there's
very little chance
of seeing one with a camera in my hands
to film it in real time so by using
camera traps we're able to capture
photographs and video the world has
never seen
to get to these places sometimes
we're waiting Waist Deep through a swamp
some places you're deep into the
Wilderness where you're going by truck
in an ATV and then hiking to get into
these really remote places
other times you're getting out of your
truck on the side of the highway
going through a chain link in barbed
wire fence
in setting of a camera to underpass
right there beneath the semis and
thousands of cars whizzing by every day
we've had cameras
burned by wildfire
drowned by hurricanes
toppled by black bears
stolen by poachers
shot by a hunter or an angry landowner
oh
oh that's a bullet that's it that's the
bullet I think
and it's taken years to get these images
when people open up the magazine and
they see that Florida panther jumping
off the page
they might not know
how difficult it was
to capture that image when I stuck my
pull out and about waist deeper water
big alligator came up and nailed me on
the hand knocked me backwards pretty
sure a case of mistaken identity this
Gator wasn't trying to eat me but it's a
reminder out here we're in these swamps
all the time
and you can get a little bit Cavalier
and forget that we're entering somebody
else's world and it's a really wild
place still and in some cases it's
taking me more than two years in one
case five years
to capture the photograph
that has the elements for the pages of
National Geographic magazine
what this project has given to me is a
chance to
spend lots of time in places like this
this has been a passport to discover
some of the most amazing places I have
ever been
still blows my mind that these places
still exist and we still have a chance
to save them
I know why I'm so sad is because
we love this place so much and I feel
lucky that I get to take volunteers and
people out here to show it to them but
to me that's still not enough like I
wish I could show everyone how special
this place is
you know I end up falling in love with
these places and I know it's something
it becomes like
Here Comes part of you in a way and then
it's like turning a chapter when we take
a system out
it takes weeks to find the spot set up
the camera and it'll take about two
hours to pack it up and carry it away so
and Sunday is the end of our our permit
into the project here so
I don't want to leave
[Music]